okay great so the first sort of um paper
that I'm going to talk about is called
emerging abilities of large language
models
um and this paper was especially cool uh
I think because we got people from
Google and deepmind and and also at
Stanford you might recognize Percy or
Tatsu or arishi I mean we got people to
sort of agree on what's the nice
framework of looking at why we want to
scale
um and emerging abilities
um
so
uh one of the things that we've seen
throughout language models is that you
sort of get these predictable gains as a
result of scaling so here's the
canonical you know Kaplan at all paper
where you can see that if you scale up
the size of the language model measure
it either in compute in data set size or
in parameters
you see that the loss on on the test set
actually goes down predictably yeah I
don't know if you're screen sharing so
people on Zoom I don't think can see the
slides okay yeah yeah sorry okay
okay
um I guess I'll say this for the third
time uh as as we've seen in language
models
if you scale up the size of the language
model uh measured either in compute uh
in data set size or a number of
parameters you can see that there's a
sort of this predictable uh Improvement
in the test loss
um
now what I'm going to be talking about
in terms of emergence is something
that's actually unpredictable
if you only look at smaller language
models so one way that emergence has
been described in the broader science
literature is it's basically seen as a
qualitative change that arises from
quantitative changes I mean it sort of
started with this article in science by
a Nobel prize winning physicist called
more is different
and I really like this post from Jacob
steinart that sort of describes
emergence and and he gives a couple of
good examples here
for example he says with uranium with a
bit of uranium nothing special happens
with a large amount of urine impact
densely enough you get a nuclear
reaction
and then also with DNA for example given
only small molecules such as calcium you
can't meaningfully encode useful
information but given larger models such
as DNA you can encode a genome
um so for this particular work uh we use
this definition of emerge abilities of
large language models in particular so
we say that ability is emergent if it is
not present in smaller models but it is
present in larger models
um and the sort of natural question here
is like how do you measure the size or
the scale of the language model and
they're sort of traditionally three axes
of scale so the training flops are the
amount of compute that you use to train
the language model
the number of model parameters or like
the the size the language model and also
the size of the training data set that
the model is trained on
um and a lot of the plots here will use
either training flops or the number of
model parameters the reason is that the
trained asset size is usually fixed for
for different size models and because
training flops is just the data set size
times model parameters you'll it you can
get a similar plot from either training
flops or number of model parameters for
most language models
um great and so the first type of
emergence yes sir go ahead
foreign
so yeah for example uh I'll just give a
I'll just give an example here which is
actually the next slide
um so basically we have this way of
interacting with language models called
few shot prompting
um and the way it works is like you know
the language model is a really good next
word predictor
and when you give the model an example
and then you ask it for an unseen uh an
unseen um like movie review for example
and then you say what's the output and
then here the language model can say
positive because it understands to use
the context from the review uh to give
the next token
um and the definition of we let that we
use for like having ability or not is
that basically a few shot prompted like
tasks for example a sentiment analysis
is emergent if it has random accuracy
for small models but above random
accuracy for large models does that make
sense so basically if if the model isn't
doing any better than random then we say
it doesn't have the ability to do this
particular task
yeah
cool
I mean I'll give a few examples here
um
so here's sort of the canonical way that
we look at plots for emergence so
basically
what we have each of these different
plots is a different task and I'll go
over some examples soon
but the way you read the plot is the
x-axis is a number of training flops or
the model scale and then the y-axis is
like the accuracy or like how good the
model is doing the task
um and then you know we have different
language models from open AI from Google
and from deepmind and then each of the
points is like a different language
model it's not a language model over the
course of training like each point is a
different language model
and what you see is that for the very
small language models
um you basically get a performance
that's that's close to random or not
being any better
um and then once you pass a certain
threshold
um you can see that the the performance
suddenly gets like a lot above uh
substantially above random and this is
what we call emergence so basically if
you were to extrapolate like the lines
uh from the small language models you
might predict that it would never you
know do better than random because it's
just a flat line but the interesting
phenomena is that when you scale up past
a certain threshold you actually do see
this emerging phenomena where the model
does a lot better than random
foreign
so let me go over some like concrete
examples
so here's uh one task it's basically a
benchmark called multitask nlu or mmlu
and basically uh what it is it's a bunch
of uh test questions uh ranging from
high school all the way to like
professional level exams
and how it works is the language model
sort of given uh for example here is a
high school math example and the
language model is given like a few
examples and then for an unseen question
it has to give the answer
and then you can see in the plot on the
right so for the model scale if you go
up to sort of 10 to the power of 22
training flops you don't actually get
any better than random accuracy on this
task but if you scale up to 10 to the 24
training flops then you see that all the
like three models there do much better
than uh than random accuracy
um yeah the
is it roughly similar or because these
are like different models straight by
different orgs
um yeah the scale is uh I think within
an order of magnitude for for these
models here yeah yeah and like every
single doc on each individual tracks is
the same data uh yes the data the data
is fixed um except for chinchilla
chinchilla uses more data for larger
models but
um I believe yeah for all the other
models here the amount of data is the
same
um yeah here's just another example to
sort of um
show it more concretely so this is a
task from the big bench Benchmark
um just as an aside the big bench
Benchmark is like 200 benchmarks uh and
basically it's like a crowdsource set of
benchmarks I'd recommend looking at if
you're doing that component work and
basically the task is the language model
has to take an English sentence and then
give the International Phonetic Alphabet
transliteration the IPA transliteration
which is basically like how to pronounce
it
um and for this for this uh task the
evaluation metric is actually blue or
like an engram overlap metric
um and and you get a similar uh
phenomena where as you uh increase the
size of language model it's flat for a
while and then suddenly the Improvement
is above random
um great
so I'll talk about another uh
interesting result I hear that that's
why it's emerging so this was a
technical report that we put out um a
couple of months ago
um and basically there's this really
interesting prize
um in or it's like a a one-time prize in
um uh in language models where uh
anthropics which is like a startup
basically had this prize where If people
could come up with a task where the
performance on the task would actually
decrease
as you increase the size of the language
model then you would get like a bunch of
money
so basically there are a lot of
submissions to this and here's one
example of like a task where they found
that the performance would actually
decrease if you increase the size of the
language model so the task is out of
created here it's like repeat my
sentences back to me and then uh the
input is like all that glisters is not
glib and then the output is uh the model
has to completely has to accurately say
a glib
um
and so what happened is for the small
language model it doesn't know the
phrase all that glisters is not gold so
it just like copies the input and
actually does get it's like 100 on that
um but then for the medium-sized
language model uh what you would see is
that the performance actually decrease
because the medium-sized language model
knows the phrase all that glisters is
not gold and then it says gold which
actually is not what the task asks it to
do yeah okay can you give a physical
estimate of 10 to the 24 plots possibly
in terms of training time or number of
gpus
um yeah so I think
um
uh 10 to the 24 flops uh is around so at
Google we use tpus and one pod of tpus I
believe is equal to like 4 000 a100s
um and 10 to the 24 flops is like two
pods uh for around six weeks or
something like that
um so it's a lot of compute to do the
pre-training
um
I don't know do you guys remember in
like chemistry class when you'd have
like moles
and it would be like 10 to the 23 and
then you're like teacher would be like
oh don't even think about like how big
this number is that's like the number of
like floating Point operations that uh
goes into the pre-training of some of
these models
um okay great anyways uh so
um yeah so so basically the medium-sized
language model will actually do worse oh
yeah did you have another question
yeah oh wait is did this one win the
prize or not I'm like um this one is uh
one of the the winner I think it's like
the third place winner or something yeah
because like I would say my initial
opinion would be like oh you can just
like put the negatives like on how you
evaluate
uh what do you mean flip a negative side
well because like all of this depends on
like which evaluations you
use yeah to measure a few years
so like it's like the
the measurement is very sparse like you
only get credit if you do it perfectly
yeah yeah like show a lot of things
emerge because like you just won't hit
it perfectly until like it's like really
optimized for a long time or like if you
take a test and then like uh evaluate it
it's like it's minus signs like looking
at like
yeah I mean they they so for this thing
they like accounted for all like you
can't just say like the task should be
do badly on something it has to be like
a meaningful sort of task
um and then I guess your your point
about like the how credits assignment or
the valuation metric works is actually a
really good one
um yeah so I guess it still kind of
counts if like you know uh I I guess the
argument is sort of the the
um
the performance might not look emergent
if you assign partial credit
um but we have like a bunch of uh I can
show example later but
um even if you use partial credit
metrics you'll often still see the same
type of emergence
um so it's not purely a phenomenon if
like uh not assigning partial credit
based on evaluation
um
well
um and then uh great so what what we
sort of sort of argued in this paper is
that yeah there might be some tasks
where the performance starts to decrease
if you use a medium-sized language model
um but if you keep scaling uh all the
way to you know the largest model that
we have at Google that's known publicly
uh Palm uh you'll see that uh the
language model I can actually go back
and do the task correctly because uh the
large language model uh also knows the
phrase all that glisters is not gold uh
but I also understands repeat my
sentences back to me
um so it's able to get 100 uh on this
task so this is a different type of uh
emergence also
um uh and a another class of emergence
that we sort of talk about
um in the paper is like an emergent
prompting technique so basically uh you
know other than future thought prompting
there's like other ways of like
interacting with the language models
um that uh
can be considered emergent yeah
um the question is did all models
undergo instruction fine tuning
um none of these models under one
instruction fine-tuning for for this
plot yeah
um great yeah so so
um yeah so one way of interacting with
language models is uh uh it by basically
finding the model using a technique
called rlhf and basically the way it
works is you have this data and humans
rate like preferences for what type of
outputs they prefer
and then the model strand on RL to sort
of optimize for human preferences
and what this plot is showing here is
that if you do this RL HF on the model
the model performance on a different
zero shot task actually gets worse for
small models you can see the the blue
line is above the Orange Line blue line
is the Baseline the word line is arlohs
and then if you do it for large models
though then you can see that the
performance actually has a positive
Delta from doing rlh
um
and so this is sort of interesting thing
where like a certain technique might
only help if you try on a large enough
language model so if you only tried on
the small small language models it'd be
tough to draw the conclusion that uh it
wouldn't help performance
um and then later I'll talk about Chain
of Thought prompting as another emergent
uh
um so here's sort of the hand wavy
diagram that I sort of used to think
about uh emergence as a framework so on
the x-axis here there's like a scale of
the language model and on the y-axis is
a sort of imaginary like you know a
scale of like a range of things that a
language model can do
and then basically you can pick like
some random Point like say 100 billion
parameters in the language model
um and there will be certain abilities
um any okay so first you can see as you
increase the size of the language model
the number of like tasks or things the
language can do increases
um and then you can see there are some
tasks where
um a one like models above 100 billion
parameters for example can do them but
models below 100 million parameters
can't do them and we call these emergent
abilities
yeah
oh it's just highlighting like
um the dark blue is like tasks that a
smaller language model wouldn't be able
to do
does that make sense yeah and then
then find the light region up top
um oh that just means like tasks that we
haven't been able to solve yet with
language models yeah
cool
and I'm curious to know do you think
that it's not that those tasks in the
white region are unsolvable and like 100
billion scale
or do you think that better models
specific training data would allow us to
get 100 billion scale to get into that
white regime yeah I definitely think
that um it's not a uh fixed
um uh I'll give an example shortly but
it's not it's not uh
you know it's not a rule that you have
to have 100 parameters to do a certain
task it's just that that happens to be
the threshold that we we've observed in
models so far and I do think with better
training data and architecture and
algorithms we can probably beat that
cool um
yeah so as Rylan just mentioned um one
example of uh getting emergence uh can
be with better data so it's not all
about scale I'll sort of give some
Nuance here so
um for this task is just one of the
tasks in the big bench Benchmark
um you can see that for like Lambda
which is a Google model on gpt3
um you actually don't get emergence from
scaling to 137 or 100 uh 137 175 million
parameters
um but when you come in with a different
language model Palm which is train on
better data
um than Lambda mgbt3 you actually can
get the submergent ability even with
this model language model so here at 62
billion parameters
um yeah so so the the challenging thing
is that's a great question
um there's like a lot of differences
between Palm and and Lambda for example
and we can't really ablate them in any
controlled way because of the cost of
pre-training but are like sort of
running hypothesis is that Palm is
trained on better data and that accounts
for a lot of the difference between
um Paul and Lambda it seem like the
smaller skills but it is possible
um yeah that's a good question so I
guess even here you can look at like for
example the Palm 8 billion model
that point there
um you can ablate it and it's like a
little bit higher but it's not really an
emergent yet at that point so it's hard
to it's hard to tell for you know for
example this particular task what the
effect is
yeah
Zoom yeah are there two different
versions of palm if not why are there
two lines
oh so I think the two lines here one is
like uh maybe three shot and then one is
like zero shot
um something like that so it just refers
to the the way that we're using the
language model either with or without
exemplars
yeah
great
I'll talk about it yeah a small ablation
here that sort of shows this so uh this
is an ablation on sort of a toy task uh
where uh basically the language model
has to know that like in English you
have to use plural verbs with plural
subjects and singular verbs with
singular subjects
um and uh the way that what we're doing
here is basically we train like these
small burnt models from scratch and then
we held out like uh we we fixed the
frequency of certain verbs in the
training data set which basically says
like okay what's the effect of seeing a
certain verb in the data more often
um in this plot uh the x-axis is like
the frequency of the verb and the y-axis
is the error rate and what you basically
see is that if you have more in domain
data so if the model sees the verb more
times it does the task a lot better I
mean this is sort of an example of like
having higher quality data or data
that's more in domain for the tasks that
you're evaluating on can make a big
difference even if you're fixing uh the
compute the size of the model and the
rest of the data
Yeah question on Zoom someone asks could
there be a way to distill emergent
abilities down to smaller models from
larger teacher models
um yeah I think so so
um
larger teacher models uh can basically
you can use them for example to generate
data and then if you fine-tune the
larger the smaller model on data it's
pretty likely that you'll be able to uh
get the ability to emerge in a smaller
model
um I'll talk about example of this too
let's see oh actually that's a next
slide so
um desired behaviors can be induced in
smaller models once you sort of know
what Behavior you want so for example
here's the instructory PT uh uh here's a
figure from the instruction PT paper
and basically the desired Behavior here
is like instruction following
and you can see that uh there's multiple
models so on the left you have these
small models that are trained with rlhf
and they actually have better
performance than larger models train on
weaker techniques
um so you can you can so basically the
point is like if you know that you want
a certain behavior that sort of you saw
previously in our emergency in an
emergent way in a larger model you can
find a way to fine-tune on that behavior
specifically and induce that behavior in
a smaller model
I guess the one of the limitations is
that like you unless you know like all
the behaviors that you want you can't
really get this natural emerging
Behavior
um uh I uh yeah another sort of
discussion Point here is that like
there's this question of like what's the
right x-axis for emergence so like right
now we mostly talk about like model
parameters and training flops but like I
guess you could like if you ask deepmind
people like how they look at it you'll
sort of get this argument that model
parameters and training flops are really
just a proxy for like how good the model
is
um and how good the model is can really
be measured by like uh perplexity or
like how well it's doing on some on some
uh Dev sets such as Wiki text 103.
um so basically you can also measure
um
uh emergence in terms of perplexity so
so here is
um wikitex perplexity
um and then you can see like on a
downstream task that as the perplexity
uh gets better there's sort of this
threshold where you're able to do a lot
better
um on the downstream task
um and there's sort of a strong
correlation right at least right now
between perplexity and training compute
so you can see like these two lines are
are pretty similar and um
basically I think uh in the future if we
have you know much better models that
are a lot smaller turn on much better
data and better algorithms then maybe
Wiki text perplexity can show a
different type of
um plot than using other uh metrics yeah
go ahead
so Wiki text uh is basically
um a uh I think it's like a subset of
Wikipedia and then perplexity is like a
measure of how well you can predict the
next word in a data set
so basically if you if you're really
good at modeling the next word on this
like particular evaluation set
um that that's sort of a measure of like
how well you understand language
that makes sense
oh this is like a held out test out
yeah
cool
um
and then a final thing that I think is
like pretty exciting about emergence is
that they're sort of uh not just like
technical emergence that we've talked
about but there's sort of sociological
changes in how the AI Community views
like scaling and how to use language
models
um so here's some examples of
um where scaling up the size of the
language model enables you to in this
sort of few shot scenario uh beat a task
specific fine-tuned language model
that's usually fine-tuned on say
thousands of of examples
so basically the green line is the prior
state-of-the-art achieved by fine-tuning
and then if you just uh and then the
blue dots basically show if you take a
pre-trained language model and you do
few shot prompting which means the
language model isn't intentionally
trained to do the task
um you can often get state-of-the-art
results just by continuing to scale up
the size of the language model and
obviously there's there's limitations
here you don't want to just keep scaling
up in order to get state of the art but
I think it's a it's a pretty big change
in people's minds that you could
actually get some of the best results uh
just by scaling up the size and language
model and doing property
uh which one this one
not sure should we in general assume oh
he said yes
okay
we said should we in general assume that
scale trumps
yeah so um that's a great question uh so
this plot is saying that um you
fine-tune and you can do uh and and okay
yeah so uh it depends on your like
particular
um uh task uh but what this plot is
saying
um is that
uh like
we're not like fine-tuned smaller models
um can do well on some tasks if you if
you target it well but for like tests
that are more complicated
um often you can do better just by
scaling um so they're sort of uh tasks
that fall into both of these categories
uh and I wouldn't say that um it's
contradictory I guess some tasks
um
you would do a lot better uh just by
um just basically the size of the model
and then other tasks if it's like a very
narrow domain or the large language
model might not be trained on that kind
of data then you would do better by fine
too
okay great
um so here's sort of a little summary
slide so basically emerging abilities
can only be observed in large models and
if you try to predict uh their emergence
just by looking at the plots for small
models then you wouldn't be able to do
it
um and I I sort of had a little
reflection on how to look at this so
emergence is really this framing of like
uh how to view new abilities that are
not intentionally built in to the
pre-training and I think the subtext for
this is super important which is like
you can see it as implicit argument for
why we should keep scaling up language
models because you don't you get these
abilities that are really hard to find
otherwise
um and the context around this is pretty
important because
um it's really expensive to to continue
scaling up these models and
um you know even like one year ago a lot
of people didn't believe that you could
do better on certain tasks just by
scaling up the size of the language
model
they sort of uh if you work in Industry
at all there's like this interesting
tension between emergence and also like
many production tasks so emergence is
sort of this like task General phenomena
where you scale up the model and it's
like really expensive but the single
model can do a lot of tasks this is sort
of like a in the direction of AGI
um and then for many production tasks
you have sort of the opposite where you
know what task it is for example
translating to Spanish and then you have
these constraints on compute because you
know when you build Google Translate for
example you don't want people to have to
wait a couple seconds just to get the
translation
and then you also happen to have a lot
of in domain data so you have for
example like you know a million uh pairs
of English Spanish sentences to train on
and this is like sort of the opposite
setting where you don't really care
about uh that the model is emergence you
can just train a very small model on the
data and do one of the tasks without
having to use lab compute
and the final point is that I think uh a
really promising research direction if
anyone is interested in doing research
is to like work on predicting future
emerging abilities and I haven't seen a
lot of work on it recently just because
I think maybe it's too hard for example
like you could only like predict
emergence for a specific task
um uh or like one way of strict
emergence might not be super General and
uh so so I haven't seen much work on
that but I think this is a pretty
promising direction to work on I mean
maybe a topic is working on it I don't
know
um okay great any questions on that
before I move on to channel.com
yeah go ahead
thank you which parameters are best
skilled to get like improve your
properties it's obviously there are many
different options for wearing glasses
or whatever
is that mostly something we just test
and then we find out which ones scale
that here gets better results or like
yeah
I would say that we don't have very
principled methods for like how to scale
these architectures
um
I'm not an expert in this but some of it
has to deal with like how many
parameters you can fit onto a particular
TPU
um uh but in general I think you scale
up like the number of intentions heads
and the embeddings like somewhat
proportionally
um but yeah I think this is like an open
research question and because you know
you can't really do ablations over these
these pre-training
um you can't really do ablations of your
pre-training it's hard to sort of uh you
know have any principled way of doing it
other than some Engineers who are in
charge of like doing it saying okay I
think this is the right thing to do and
then it kind of works and go with it
yeah do you have any indication of the
asymptotic behavior of the scalping if
you expect that eventually you would you
know reach either some Plateau a split
Planet but non-zero loss or it would
just go all the way down to zero
um yeah that's a great question
um
I think I mean there's uh you mean on
like uh perplexity or like some uh on a
particular task or just in general on
like Network predictions well seems like
this is also pretty General pretty task
independent right it's like emergent
scaling yeah but take the limit of
infinite parameters then even
analytically is there any sense of
whether how that can move
yeah I have no clue um I think if if uh
like for most of these tasks there's
like a limit to accuracy like 100 for
example so there's some there's some
sort of asymptote there but I guess
um the deeper question that you might be
asking is like can a language model like
perfectly know like
you know how to predict the next word
for any given input
um and maybe like I mean I guess there's
some like limit to like
um like if I say a sentence um there are
like two possible next words or
something and you might not be able to
get guessed that perfectly
um
so I think there's some limit but like I
think we're far from reaching that limit
and there's still a lot of Unsolved
tasks that
um sort of indicate that there's a lot
of Headroom
yeah if researchers are interested in
studying emergence yeah what family of
different size models is publicly
available or best for study
yeah good question
um
so uh I think the openai API has like a
lot of language models and we actually
use that a lot even at Google it's used
to study emergence and that's sort of
one way of doing it and actually a lot
of these models are currently free
um they're rate limited but they're free
so that so we also use that
um
I think there's also uh
smaller language models like for example
there's like a ul2 model that's like 20
billion parameters but I guess you're
right there there is sort of this
challenge where like the small language
models you won't see a lot of these
emerging behaviors so you kind of have
to either train
um
uh yeah so you kind of have to uh either
use like open AI API for now or or wait
until people train larger models I guess
there's also the uh Bloom and like you
guys probably know better than me like
opt models that are publicly available
but I haven't seen a lot of experiments
on them
yeah yeah
so like my question is are there are
there emergent abilities that like are
accessible in the lower parameter
reviews
there might be like somebody maybe not
like Chain of Thought but like are there
some that are like yeah definitely I
think uh in the paper we had like the
list of a couple dozen abilities that
would be emerging at like 8 billion
parameters or like six people in
parameters or something like that yeah
yeah
the first question is do you see
strategy tactics between the larger Tech
firms differing systematically in
studying these models whereas basically
everyone taking the same approach
um
I I I wouldn't say that everyone is
taking the same approach
um I think
as one example anthropic takes like a
very safety Centric approach and they're
super interested in like emerging
abilities because uh there could be
emergent abilities that are undesirable
and they want to predict those types of
things
um I also don't know what happens at
other companies other than at Google so
I can't really speak too much to that
yeah the second question what are some
examples of tasks or abilities that have
not yet emerged even in models like
Lambda and chat GPT Etc
oh yeah I have uh maybe I'll just show
this real quick
um
there's like a nice list somewhere
so
so yeah so basically what we did is um
there's like 200 tasks in big bench and
then we basically classified them into
like smoothly increasing emergent with
gpt3 or Lambda emergent with palm and
then flat which is like no model better
than random so I think if you look at
any of these tasks here
um they should still not have emerged
yet and if you can uh get them to merge
that'd be interesting yeah
sorry
questions oh okay yeah this is not a
super uh I think this is like a couple
months old so sorry
yeah yeah
oh 20 Questions okay yeah
yeah I think
like the cool thing is like you can see
over time right like originally like
maybe only like these were you know
emergent and then when Palm came out
you'd see a couple dozen more abilities
you can imagine and then you know I
suspect
um you know in a year or two most of
these will become emergent and uh we'll
need harder benchmarks yeah there's
another question why doesn't Google take
as much of a safety center approach like
you said in Project notes are there
reasons to believe harmful capabilities
wouldn't be emerging
um yeah I don't want to answer the
question on behalf of Google I just can
only talk about uh my own opinions
um but I think the reality is that
Google if even if you look at like the
amount of research that Google does it
might not be in the large language
models very specifically but like the
amount of Safety Research that we do I
think is more than andropic if you if
you actually look at like the number of
papers published don't quote me on this
but uh I think that's correct
um okay
uh uh great
so
yeah I'll talk about um Chain of Thought
prompting so basically channel.prompting
is uh this way of doing reasoning
multi-step reasoning with large language
models
um and
um
yeah I wanted to say that I get super
exciting to see like a lot of people at
Google working on this and also to see
um uh Sundar CEO present this at our
last year's uh Google IO press event
um
and uh basically the motivation for this
is that we want language models to do
like more complicated tasks that you
know for example uh we know language
models can do easy tasks like Cinema
analysis or translation but what about
like more complicated tasks that might
even take a human uh minute or more to
do
and the goal here is to basically guide
them with metadata so for example
instead of just giving like an input
output pair we want to give them the
entire reasoning process and have them
mimic that
um and the basically you can see here uh
you know in a standard prompt you have
like the question and then the answer
and then you have a question in the
model gives a new answer unfortunately
it's wrong
um and then with Chain of Thought
prompting
um uh you give the model a question and
then kind of like how your teacher would
ask you to show your work uh you give
like the uh the Chain of Thought is what
we call it or basically a reasoning path
um and then you give the final answer
and then when the model excuse this
unseen question now it's able to give
the reasoning path and then give the
correct final answer
and the way that we add these uh prompts
into the prompt is basically we just
manually write a couple and then add it
into the top
um so let me just show how that works
um so this was the open API
and basically
uh here's like the non-chain f.way of
doing it so basically you would have
um
question answer question answer question
answer and then new question about you
know cafeteria 23 apples they use 20 and
make lunch and bought six more how many
apples they have
I'm in the model uh gets it wrong
and the only difference with chain F dot
is that you give these uh intermediate
reasoning paths
um before giving the final answer so
here's a path there's a there's a
reasoning chain there's another
reasoning chain and then uh now the
model for this unseen question
uh gives the entire reasoning process
um and then this actually enables the
model to get it correct
I'll give another quick example
[Music]
so here the task is uh just take the
last letters of the words and Bill Gates
so like L from Bill and S from Gates and
then concatenate them and the answer
should be LS
and then here the model gets it wrong
the answer should be NK
it says SK
and then if you do Chain of Thought
obviously this has become it becomes
very easy for the model so you know it
says the last letter of Bill is L the
last letter Gates is s the answer is LS
and then here it's able to do the last
layer for elon's M and the last letter
of mosque is K and answer is NK
um so any any is this clear any
questions about what's going on here
okay
um
so basically we can have these similar
plots where the x-axis is the model
scale the y-axis is the performance
so on the left we have this math board
question Benchmark called gsmak it's
basically like questions that you'd see
in like an elementary school math test
and you can see the the blue dot is
standard and the purple star is Chain of
Thought I mean basically you see that
the Chain of Thought if you use a large
enough model does a lot better than
standard prompting
um it actually beats the fine-tuned
state of the art um at the time
a similar example is is on this
Benchmark called strategy QA and what
strategy is it's basically like this uh
World Knowledge plus Common Sense
reasoning Benchmark so the question
would be like can you hide a basketball
in the sand cat's ear and then the model
would uh say like you know basketball is
about this size the sand cat's ear is
that those server would not fit
um and now this Benchmark you can also
see that we can beat the fine-tune state
of the art from before just by using
Chain of Thought with a large enough
language model
um so one way we use this is that we
evaluate a Chain of Thought on a certain
subset of of big bench tasks so we
created this subset called Big bench
hard and basically it's like 23
challenging tasks from Big bench where
like no model had done better than uh
the average human Raider
um so the way that you prompt the model
is that you'd have like a task
description question options chain of
dot uh and then the test time question
um and so I'll give a couple examples of
like tasks here
uh so uh one example is navigate uh
basically what the language model has to
do and this task is uh it has to
basically follow these so the question
is like if you follow these instructions
do you return to the starting point turn
left turn right take five steps take
four steps turn around take nine steps
um and then the model uh following the
future exemplars is able to like
basically track state after all of uh
all of the actions and then at the end
it says okay are we at the final answer
so the answer are we at the Fun are we
at the original location I mean if it is
zero zero the answer is yes
um
just give an example of another task
um here's a task that's like very easy
for humans basically word sorting so
like there's a list of words Burley
Baylor I'm not gonna read them and
basically uh the model has to sort them
alphabetical order
um and here the model can follow the
future employers so you have this uh
pretty complicated like
um uh chain of dot where the model has
to like sort each of the subparts and
then finally it gets to the the final
answer which is correct
foreign
so here's sort of this result summary on
on this subset um of big bench so you
can see okay uh we have uh two metrics
uh one is just the average performance
on all these tasks
um and the second uh is the percent of
tasks that are above uh the average
human reader so average numerator is 67
Max human right is 94. and then prior
results uh the model was doing like way
worse it was like 50. I mean this is
sort of by Def by construction of this
subset
um and then we used code eventually O2
which is like one of the open AI models
um and actually you can use this one for
free with open API and basically uh if
you do answer only prompting without
Chain of Thought then you sort of are
being the average numerator on like five
of 27 but if you use chain f.prompting
then the performance increases by this
uh pretty decent amount and you're able
to pass the human average human other
majority of tasks
um and then below is just this
visualization of uh the tasks that are
doing worse than humans in red and then
better than humans in thank you yeah
two questions isn't this similar to rlh
Spirit at least
uh is what similar
I'm not sure
um yeah I think uh it's uh there
I wouldn't call it similar so like Chain
of Thought is basically you take a
pre-trained language model and you use a
prompting technique that includes
intermediate musica
um the way that rlhf works is that you
have this additional data that you want
to fine-tune the model on and you have a
preference model that sort of predicts
like how well does a certain output
um
uh uh uh How likely is that to be
preferred by humans and then rlhf uh
what that does is it fine-tune them all
it fine-tunes like the language model to
do well on the preference model's
prediction so basically uh it's it's
sort of aligning the model with what
humans would prefer
is there a second question
okay um
um yes uh the short answer is yes
um
the sort of complicated thing about that
is that you have to have like Chain of
Thought intermediate steps and those are
pretty
um uh it can be costly to sort of uh to
gather that data and to do the fine
today
I like prompt Engineering in general is
just an artifact that won't be necessary
for larger scale models that are better
able to understand
yeah so that's a great question
um uh basically the question is like how
like ephemeral is like prompt
engineering gonna be
um I think uh we'll find out but um some
initial intuitions are that like for
easy tasks that are like you know easy
to describe and maybe they're multiple
choice
um larger models will probably be more
robust to prompt engineering and there's
sort of less you can do with that but I
think as language models get more
powerful
um it'll sort of be more normal to use
them on a lot a lot more challenging
tasks and in those tasks you'll have to
specify exactly what you want them all
to do et cetera so I think there'll
still be some room for prompt
engineering there at least in the near
future
and then the other one basically sorting
the words
yeah so I mean I see that's okay because
one thing that it does that took a while
but with that model also become better
do you have to give the channel thought
for like the topic words are the best
yeah that's a great question
um so uh for some tasks where you've
seen similar data in pre-training the
model can do really well even if the
Chain of Thought is from another task
um so for example like math word
problems you actually don't really need
a math Chain of Thought because the mod
already knows how to do that but like
for a tasks like this
you probably haven't seen any data
that's like the Chain of Thought here so
without task specific exemplars you
probably wouldn't do super well on tasks
like this without
um manually writing them uh for for
other examples
uh yeah
um
do you pursue the model as like if I was
a person how would I do this better or
is it like trying to give it more like
uh compute in order to like like before
yesterday enter yeah great question
um
I think my motivation was just thinking
about it just as you said like what's
going on in sort of a human's mind while
they try to solve this math question
um and uh well if you notice like at
least some humans will think actually in
natural language
um so like if you just like think about
like if you pay attention a lot to like
what's going on in your mind you
actually notice that you sometimes you
think a language and so while the
language too so that was kind of the
motivation behind
um asking language model to do that and
I think
um uh one thing that sort of went well
is that uh the development of like this
technique actually coincided with like
the development of palm and so
um
uh yeah basically having the model Palm
sort of allowed us to do a lot uh better
tasks or a lot more challenging tasks uh
using Chain of Thought
yeah
like we're saying that it matters is the
absolute number of examples of such a
thought process or whatever in the data
set
um or in the front unit is that is that
the main significant thing or is it like
is this relative number of frequency of
like those examples are just like
negative examples which are like not
good examples of content reasons do
those matter as much as just the
absolute number of
um for example
yeah good question
um
so I guess the challenging thing is like
we can't really measure how many similar
examples are in the training center uh
you know it's it's hard to do that well
and uh no I don't think anyone's done
that before so it's for this open
question of like why uh China thought
even works because you actually don't
see
a similar data like that in the training
set
um
yeah I think it's open question like why
it works
think about like how um
but like how do you actually think like
in like what a situation for the model
or like I mean understand like a shift
in for a specific task like some weights
get like warm and
Focus
yeah I don't really think about it in
terms of like what's going on in the
weights I guess the way that I think
about it is that like
um it'd be unfair for me to like give
you a math question and ask you to give
me the answer within like half a second
which is basically like what you're
doing with the model and when you don't
do a Chain of Thought right you're
basically asking this like challenging
question and the model doesn't have
enough compute to like solve it in one
pass to give you the next answer
immediately
um I think the second thing that
um
I sort of think about is that like the
model has learned like a compositional
set of skills
um during during pre-training so maybe
it hasn't really learned like you know
this particular navigate task during
pre-training but it's doing other things
right so I'm like okay if you uh take
five steps and you're facing this maybe
yeah you should add five here or
something like that right and it's
learned how to do pattern matching so
uh maybe in the future exemplars it can
match sort of uh what the reasoning path
is with like what the question was and
so there's sort of these little skills
that the model may know
um and then maybe if you can combine
them together in some clever way then
you can get them all to solve a more
challenging problems
um okay
Iran uh how much time do we have
okay 50 okay
okay
uh okay great
a good example of how we can
get away yeah
is
yeah okay great yeah feel free to keep
asking questions if you have any um
so uh
yeah here's another example of emergence
so basically you can see there's three
models here in structured BTT codex and
poem Chain of Thought in blue non-chain
of thought uh is in uh is in Gray and
then you can see uh you actually have to
have sufficient model scale to get Chain
of Thought to work well
um and uh I guess the intuition here is
that like if you have a really small
model uh the the model sort of will keep
repeating itself or not say anything
coherent Navigator final answer which is
why using Chain of Thought for the small
models doesn't really work well and then
for the large models obviously you know
for multiple step map like for
multi-step problems uh the model is
going to uh be able to solve the task at
a lot higher accuracy with Chain of
Thought
okay
um and another cool thing about Chain of
Thought is there are sort of some tasks
where
um you sort of wouldn't get emergent
Behavior at all uh so you know emergence
hasn't been unlocked uh yet
um but uh you can see that the if you
use Chain of Thought you can unlock this
emergent performance uh in in smaller
models so uh one example here is like
multi-step arithmetic where like I don't
know if you'll ever you know maybe I
don't want to say never but like it you
can it's hard to imagine a model like
getting this you know here's a question
and then the next token is correct
that's pretty hard to solve in one step
um but with Chain of Thought you can get
like you know 50 accuracy on this just
by having the model
um output
um these intermediate uh intermediate
reducing steps
definitely yeah yeah but like
then there's this question of like what
happens empirically right and like I
understand that like it isn't
necessarily a lot of space
yeah so like
um my question just like how
uh tell the difference like maybe if
they're like ways to tell the difference
between like things that have on a merch
because like there's just like no space
or like
um like like there's so many tasks that
like it kind of like allotted any any
space to specifically do that one versus
like uh like the the task is so hard
that like but
it just can't even if you like it
yeah capacity to try and do it yeah
that's a good question I think
um
there seems to be like some subset of
tasks where uh it's just like doesn't
fit well with the way that we train
language models so for example like in
language models we use tokens right and
so if you give it like the token four it
actually doesn't take the number four it
takes like this embedding that's like
you know 1000 Dimensions or something or
if you like give it a word and ask it to
reverse like the letters this is like a
super easy task but like the way we
train the model doesn't actually look at
the letters and stuff
so I mean there's a certain subset of
tasks where like
um it doesn't really just fit well with
the way that we train Transformers and
um you can actually like I mean I think
these if you really care about these
tasks you can just solve them uh using
like code or something like that
um but yeah I I think uh I don't think
like this is really an inherent um
something that would never emerge
because it's too hard
um yeah
um so the question someone asked is do
you think China thought would be a
viable interpretability technique for
very Advanced AI systems and they
mentioned that there's some research by
tropical externalized reasoning
oversight by camera
oh will it be a viable interpretability
technique for advanced AI
um yeah am I supposed to repeat this
yeah yeah sorry please oh so the
question is
um
can chain if not be a viable
interpretability technique for AI I
think um there's no guarantee that like
the Chain of Thought is how the model
actually arrives at the final answer but
often you can use it to like sort of
debug like why isn't the model getting
this question correct or like
um what what can we do better in the
Chain of Thought to help them all get
this correct
um I haven't read the anthropic paper
that that was mentioned so I actually
don't know the answer to that
um okay
um another uh interesting uh result that
we had here was that uh you can actually
do like multilingual Chain of Thought
prompting
um and so basically what we've had is
like we translated this like uh you know
benchmark of math report problems than
10 languages
um and then we prompt them uh the model
to do it in like say Bengali and then
the model has like basically do the math
problem in Bengali
um and give the final answer
um I think the cool thing about this is
that like this input is like highly
improbable right so like Bengali is like
0.01 of the pre-training data and uh you
know math word problems are probably
even smaller subset of that
um and basically the interesting thing
is the model can actually do like uh
these types of questions pretty well uh
to probably surprising degrees like you
know if you ask people before I show
them this result like oh how well can
the model do you like these math
questions in Swahili like oh probably
like 10 but actually
um even like you know very unrepresented
languages like uh Swahili or Bengali or
uh Telugu and and Thai
um the model can do so like surprisingly
well despite the fact that they only
occupy like a very small uh subset of
the the pre-trained data
yeah
most of my experience
with nothing like explicitly training
these languages right it seems to sort
of like derive reasoning independent of
language to some extent yeah you do the
reasoning actually it's kind of funny
like sometimes it always looks like it
does the reasoning in English and it
translates back to the other language
because like answers it gives you a sort
of like if you like reasoned in English
and then translate to the other thing
did you think that like uh learning the
like structure of a language and
learning reasoning abilities are like
somewhat separate in large language
models or that like even inherently will
like learn shade of thought reasoning
within that language within the
structure of the language like the way
thought Works in that language
yeah that's a great question I'm not
sure how to measure that but uh I've
definitely thought about it I think the
language I mean based on these results
like you definitely Pro you probably
didn't have any math questions in
Swahili for the for the model to learn
from and I think definitely there's
something language agnostic going on
where the model learns reasoning sort of
independently of the language and then
it can express it in different languages
if it needs to yeah but I I don't have a
I don't think anyone I don't think we
know the answer yet yeah
um
yeah so so basically like one question
that uh comes up frequently is like why
does scaling up improve Chain of Thought
um and one way of looking at this is
like we can take a smaller model like
pom62b and see like what types of errors
are fixed from scaling up to 540 going
parameters I mean you can see that like
for for these three categories that we
came up with
um some of all of them get fixed so
scaling seems to have this like sort of
universal effect on improving uh
different types of Errors from solid
models
um and then here's this the same hand
wavy diagram and expressed in different
ways so basically you have like some
tasks that are doable with standard
prompting so in blue
um and then uh the the goal of
channel.prompting is a sort of increase
the sub the the set of tasks that we can
do so for example now uh the ones shown
in uh Pink include math word problems
symbolic reasoning and com
challenging Common Sense reasoning yeah
one more question have you done any
compilations to figure out how uh like
much is any of this contribution just
because of the fact that you do more
complications when you put in longer
prompts like uh you know like you put
multiple passes through the model you
create multiple embeddings for sort of
like you know adjust the things the
model is looking at in a way yeah how
much would I like have you tried
non-shade of thought prompts with like
same token lengths yeah yeah we tried
with like uh XXXX or something it
doesn't really it doesn't work
so I think it's not just about the
compute I think it's about
the language guiding the model uh as
part of the reasoning yeah
and describing the problem in more
details or not being champion I know
this is like a super range question I'm
just very curious about like
it's the interesting
property and I'm very curious like
exactly how
yeah you mean like describing the
question in three different ways
more kill instead of like
to do a step-by-step thing and seeing
how that like yeah I haven't tried that
but I would be uh surprised if that
worked
yeah that doesn't work as well okay yeah
but it depends on the task also so like
yeah yeah yeah
um it that seems to be the case yeah
yeah
that's your calculation
towards the answer like anyway you know
like in a way like in a black population
the chain of salt is like a very sort of
structured thing it's like what if the
same structure is bizarre but like we
use some more random things
yeah
um you could try it I would be surprised
if it works I I I I think like
outputting tokens
um is pretty important for the for the
model yeah
okay
um
so we're doing all the time okay great
so uh the last part I think is a pretty
cool trick with chain of thoughts so
basically
um
what people usually do is they'll just
generate one Chain of Thought
um and then they'll take the final
answer but there's this nice shirt
called self-consistency where you can
use like temperature sampling with the
model to generate like a bunch of
different uh reasoning pads and final
answers
um and then if you just take a majority
vote over the final answers this ends up
like improving performance by like a
pretty big margin so uh for example here
you can see on gsmak which is like the
math word problem data set
um the Improvement goes from like uh you
know the performance like 56 and then if
you do self-consistency then it becomes
74 which is like a pretty big
Improvement
oh I think 40. so it increases the cost
of the inference time compute
um but uh yeah it improves performance
by a lot
change battery over yeah
um I think uh it depends on the uh sorry
the question is how many chains do you
need to get a performance gain uh I
think the um
the answer really depends on the data
set but usually you can get something
good with like 16 I think
oh sorry the other question how does the
temperature change the way the model
works
okay uh the question is how does the
temperature change the way the model
Works basically when you use temperature
decoding the language model can like
stochastically pick one of the outputs
instead of always picking the highest
probability next word so basically you
get these like more stochastic outputs
that are still uh based on what the
language model has learned but it's just
a little bit more random
okay
um and then like finally like yeah
self-consistency also seems to be
emerging ability I guess part of it is
because Chain of Thought is emergent
because uh you wouldn't get you know any
better than random performance
um uh uh without uh doing Chain of
Thought but um uh yeah you kind of see
this big Delta from self-consistency for
larger models
um
great so uh
uh I'm gonna run out of time let me just
go to uh
I'll just talk about this a little bit
so
um I think uh in addition to just purely
scaling up the language model which is
only available to like people in
Industry I think there's like a couple
interesting directions to
um to work on
um one is like better prompting and
characterization of wing
responsibilities I think right now we're
sort of just at the edge of uh you know
knowing what the best way to prompt
language models is
um
there's also like pretty good applied
work so like uh you can use language
models I've heard to train therapists
Let's help with creative writing to help
with science I think chat GPT has really
shown
um what language funnels can do in this
regard
um I think benchmarks are also something
that's pretty lacking because I think uh
we solved benchmarks pretty quickly
um for example Palm beat the average
human on big bench uh you know within a
year or something a big bench coming out
so I think we need more uh benchmarks
and that's that's that I think that's
going to be an important contribution
and then the final one is like how can
we like uh have compute efficient
methods to to make language models
better
um so that uh you know it's it's less
expensive to use them and more people
get to use them
um great so uh I'll end here
um and feel free to email me if you have
any any feedback and if you're
interested in Google uh yeah feel free
to meet as well awesome thanks thank you
[Applause]